c'est la grande nouveauté de Montini le
breteneux cette année pour la première
fois les inontains peuvent déposer leurs
sapins dans l'un des 10 centres de la
ville pour les recyclés les symin sont
transformés en paillage sur chaque point
de dépôt par une broyeuse ces paillages
des différentes collectes sont
réutilisés par la direction
environnement des espaces verts pour
remplir le manque de végétation des sols
depuis le 2 janvier le ramassage a lieu
une fois par semaine le but de la
collecte est de limiter le nombre de
déchets dans la ville une quarantaine de
sapins est collecté puis broyé pendant
environ 30 minutes
le broyage commence après la coupe des
bûches sur chaque site on ramasse en
fait seulement les sapins verts donc les
les épicéa les abiè enfin donc les
sapins de Noël et les les Nordman les
pour les plus courants mais sans
décoration sans bûche sans sac à
sapin éventuellement on enlève aussi les
sapins floqués sauf floqué
givré qui pour l'instant la technique ne
permet pas de les mettre en en
compostage ou en en déchetterie pour
tous les intéressés la collecte des
sapins c'est jusqu'au 14 janvier dans
tous les sites mis à disposition pour
l'occasion